yeah oh my God he's man of this man of
that yeah yeah girl they all they do is
confirmation by it and they'll always
sabotage like unless the guy is an
absolute simp they're gonna sabotage
like women's relationships that they do
have when they are happy unless they're
like they'll only not do it if the guy's
an absolute simp who lets her do
whatever she wants so let's do a let's
do a hypothetical scenarios pill you
find a guy you get married right and
you speak the way you speak within this
space okay right
those those modern day women those
Super Saiyan feminists right they're
gonna try and destroy your relationship
just to make themselves use that need to
be right yeah just to make themselves be
right oh well she couldn't even hold a
relationship down because now they're on
why it's power not in a relationship
what's wrong with her why is she not
married so they're trying to destroy
yourself it's always the personal
attacks but like is what I'm saying true
or is it not true and that's and that's
like that's the that's all you need to
know and you could they could go after
anything yeah everything no I actually I
was thinking I like I feel like I'd
rather date a guy that has no idea like
what my YouTube channel is right it's
like because if they see you in a happy
relationship do you think they're not
going to try and come for that oh no
they will Oh They'll Come for that I
mean I've been in like a public
relationship before and I kind of I've
seen the problems that come with it
Devin it's there's a lot of problems
that come with it they are vindictive
and evil man like I even remember after
doing the um the show that we've done on
the possible Bros right a few weeks ago
some of the comments that I got
from women I'm just like listen if you
because women are like we don't care
about guys going abroad
and on the other hand they're making
whole videos about guys I'm just saying
we should learn from them like that's
what I say like why on Earth if
someone's winning okay like if you see a
a particular demographic winning yeah
winning winning stop needing them let's
yeah let's let's take notes I'm like
what the what recipes you all know that
are making these menopause exactly but
the thing is it's the Privacy especially
if they're average looking I'm like but
it's the price of an ego pill right of
the modern day one the pride and the ego
makes them think that they are the ones
that know everything everyone outside of
them doesn't know ish they don't know
[ __ ] right so it's like what do those
Filipino women know what do those tie
with something they're the most swiped
or like Asian chicks are the most swiped
right on dating at something no they
don't know nothing because I know and
that's and that is the ego of the one
and that's what they say Pride becomes
pride comes before the fall
that's what's gonna happen to Monday
women
Pride's gonna come before the fall we
got another we got another call yeah we
could do we can do that one more yeah
like one more we'll do one more cool
thanks listen
we got
oh we got a lady oh girl this never
happens hi
hi sorry
my husband's a big fan that's how I
found your show and I find it very
informative because I've been with my
husband since I was 19. and I'm now 30
and I didn't know anything about modern
dating and it's really opened my eyes
about a lot of people my age or even a
little bit around it
um how her theme
they're treating the dating pool and
it's really eye-opening
do you sense you could tell she's mayor
I could tell she was married when she
opened the calls he's like you feel the
warp coming from though okay like the
happiness like you see that go on what
did you want to say
um so what what made you want to get
married at 19
oh I well
I would say get married at night to me
but um basically married I didn't have
the best uh family life and my dad died
at 18 and I moved out of the house and I
finished high school and then I moved
hundreds of miles away
and I really just wanted to find
somebody who wanted to love me for the
rest of my life and I want to love them
for the rest of their life and that was
the main
goal and then everything for that is
negotiable and working together as long
as we're not abusing each other in any
way and we're open to improving
ourselves
and what do you think of the topic
um The Fallout of feminism 10 to 15
years
where are you at by the way
I don't think Society will end I think
we're always predicting our end and I do
feel that
When Things become more extreme they end
up plugging themselves off and recenter
kind of like when it gets to elections
it's a race to the edges and then the
race to the middle
I'm are you familiar with those
political
terms no no I'm not I'm not gonna lie
so when you let's say in the United
States when you're running for a
candidate you race to your political
parties Democratic Republican you're
like completely this and then you're get
to the later stages and then you race to
the middle so you can get some more
votes oh I understand I understand yeah
okay
so when things become extreme eventually
they start recently
so have you
experienced I guess obviously being
married have you seen the experience of
women your age who are not married
um
not really okay
um
um and they who are also married are
they also married no actually know I was
the first one married okay
um but one was a free spirit and she
never really was ever in a relationship
with people who didn't know that she was
that and she actually recently got
married two years ago
and then I have another friend who
actually has been on a long-term
adventure for structure but um
two kids now long-term Adventure what
does that mean look what's a long-term
Adventure I think she won
he wanted children and she wanted like
the family and The Purge basis but she
wasn't really seeking
those things out and yeah
but you're like okay
is that your is that your child there
yeah she is she's almost ready for bed
so she's got the last like 10 minutes
before she gets to run around basically
not destroy the house
but be free
where are you at actually what you're
saying with the warmth no that's what
I'm saying like you could like tell them
you can tell what someone before you
even hear the kid you could tell when
they're like married and have a family
I'm in uh Michigan oh okay okay that's
what I've noticed in Michigan people
seem to get married younger and like
start families younger there oh I'm from
California I just moved so my husband
and I after we've been together a while
uh we wanted to be closer to his family
and it's always originally from Michigan
who's gonna retire in a few years and
move back here to his hometown so we
decided to move here and start our house
her family
you know get our house and stuff and
then he's retiring and he's not close to
a year or so now that he's gonna be
coming up back here
well thank you for calling in I
appreciate it
yeah thank you guys and have a wonderful
okay bye-bye
you know it's like a warmth
she's got a whole Christmas house yeah
it's like it's like uh you feel that as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible